I am happy!
I know myself!
I am not personally
responsible for anything.
Can I just apologize
about what I look like?
Uh, I didn't have any time
to change.
I had to, like, run here
straight from my dad's
worst nightmare.
The show is still
gonna be filled with
21st century cynicism,
the self-objectification
encouraged by social media,
the late capitalist
co-option
of the queer aesthetic.
I'm kidding.
Can you imagine?
This is my story.
I'm not into
conspiracy theories.
Not because I don't think
they're true.
Get him!
No, I'm kidding.
People are so critical of
young people at the moment.
Young people are all
so desperate
to play the victim,
and I take that
extremely personally.
I came here
to raise awareness.
I haven't decided of what.
Sex is really where I come
into my own as an actor.
Wow!
I'm actually just
very interested
in the layered,
poetic symbolism of anal.
That's a poem I wrote.
I do this as representation.
You know I'm one of
the first ever Jewish people
to try stand-up comedy?
This is the first song
I, like, ever wrote,
so it might be a bit
pretentious or adolescent.
But it's just a song about
my lived experiences
being a twenty-something
and growing up in this
increasingly scary time.
Tonight
I'm young tonight
And I like to start
with some singing.
No, we don't have time.